she lost last time which is pretty uh
but this is a tweet that she put
yesterday I want to get your thoughts on
this if you can pull it up she said the
Red Wave did not happen Republicans and
independents stayed home do not complain
about the results if you did not do your
part so what do you think about this
tweet from Myra Flores and Richard I'll
wrote you first she's right she's 100
right she should have won
she should have won she was just popular
she's popular she should have won she's
not she's not wrong when again when we
go back and we're watching all the when
we're watching all the the the the the
the polls and we're watching how close a
lot of these races are it's that's not
that's not that's not how this thing was
supposed to be nobody projected it to be
this way and she's right I think a lot
of people simply either either they were
big on the abortion thing or they just
did not show up and but by the way just
so you know just going back I don't want
to go back backtrack Pat but just a lot
of Hispanics really do believe that your
vote doesn't count just so you know that
like a lot of my boys are like bro I'm
not going to go vote in California it
doesn't well I know but I'm saying they
believe that in general it's a general
belief but in this case she was running
for house Kennedy right that's a little
bit different than running for governor
because you're talking about in the
house you're talking about a district
we're not talking about the whole state
correct so she lost her District but a
lot of people don't think that they're
vocals that's very popular amongst the
Hispanic community that your vote
doesn't count
who did she lose to uh what was the um
Tyler
I can't remember who uh Myra Flores yeah
who did she lose
I
was following so many of these
if you can pull up who she lost to
because and while we're looking at that
there's a whole issue in in Texas and if
you were to take a look at the the
governor county map and you see that
there were really there are three
texases now there is all the communities
that go on the border
um the real Great RGV you know Corpus
you know everything all the way down
there on the border then you've got
rural Texas and then you've got core
Houston core Austin and core Dallas and
they're like blue dots and you look at
what happened in whatever bitter
O'Rourke and so Beto O'Rourke lost again
um and what was interesting about that
is you look how we lost he didn't lose
his bad on the border communities which
stayed blue for him because of turnout
so she's right there was a the the
turnout was not down there and I think
they thought they had this thing covered
and even the polls were wrong on you
know so Beto lost by more and the polls
were off but you have to look at where
everything was and it was really
eye-opening if you've got that map at
some point to take a look at what the
Border communities were for beta
O'Rourke versus the rest of the state
beta was running for governor he was
running against a good question about
Beto you lived in Texas for a decade and
the same way has that guy won anything
when's the last time he won anything no
I mean listen not Statewide no you have
to you have to so so this is this is the
part like all I'm thinking about is as a
strategist a few things you got to be
thinking about so by the way this school
the reason why I asked who she lost so
she lost a guy named Vicente Gonzalez if
you read the comments go back to the
Myra tweet that I just gave you can you
pull that up and just go to the comment
section below just zoom in a little bit
so we can read what people are saying
what people are saying zoom in zoom in a
little bit it's not allowing okay there
you go look at the first comment a
Democratic candidate with 2000 Twitter
followers beat you let that sink in you
have 371 000 followers
do no Democratic Congressman Vince
Vincente Gonzalez just passed just won
over 2 000 followers you got rejected
right go a little lower then he said
unto Felicia keep going Lord keep going
Lord keep going Lord keep going lower
wrong we did our part we showed up in
record numbers and voted you out bye-bye
massive L all this stuff that they say
here's the part I also don't know if I'm
if I if I uh if I run a sales
organization and one of my sales guys
goes out there and says well listen guys
you guys didn't show up and you didn't
do your part that's why we lost you guys
didn't sell no no the leader gets the
responsibility I I don't think this
concept about you didn't go Shake enough
hands I'd much rather put the onus on
myself if you look at Charlie Chris he's
first candidate ever to lose a Statewide
okay election as an independent as a
Republican and as a Democrat no one
likes a flip-flopper it's the reason why
a John Kerry is not a president and his
entire trajectory since he was in high
school was this guy's one they're gonna
end up being a what he he looks like a
president he looks like Lincoln if you
put him side by side they have a similar
kind of a look similar height he's a
flip-flop American people don't like
that bitter O'Rourke is just not a good
leader he's not a candidate that's it's
formidable so both the left and the
right and certain areas chose somebody
that was not good for that market so a
Dr Oz may have done better in a
different Market you don't relate to
Pennsylvania so so the candidate you
chose for that market a person that's
worth 75 million dollars you want me to
go in Pennsylvania get the votes of
people that are like dude I don't relate
to you you know I don't I don't live
your life I don't have that so there's
some of these things now Trump worked in
the National
you know uh uh election as when he ran
for office president but he had a
Swagger he pushed Trump that Oz was
maybe like him so both sides get a bit
of a blame on NBA draft toward your
future looks bright hat click over here
and to watch the entire podcast click
here take care everybody
[Music]